[Musique]
les québécois consomment en moyenne 69 g
de sucres libres par jour c'est
l'équivalent de 25 salles 2 kg de sucre
par personne par année
on aime le sucre on aime le goût dont on
connaît maintenant les impacts d'une
surconsommation de sucre régulière sur
la santé est donc là on veut on veut
faire de meilleurs choix mais on aime
quand même encore le suc
pour faire de meilleurs choix
l'industrie nous propose une multitude
de produits des sucres et des
édulcorants pur brut naturel on voit
cristaux de sucre de canne naturelles
comme le sucre blanc était artificielle
aux règles sophistiqué outils plus fin
mais au final on part de là même canne à
sucre est sensiblement le même processus
de transformation lui une étude
récemment réalisée qui aura montré qu'au
canada les jeunes adultes avec
perception plus positive par rapport à
sucre qu'on disait de ruth
comparativement au sucre blanc
traditionnel et selon l'appellation
qu'on avait des différents types de
succès français la perception santé du
produit les appellations qui peuvent
donc influencer nos choix
selon la chercheuse lors ce lait qui
étudie les comportements des
consommateurs
on se rend compte que la naturalité ça
fait partie des critères de sélection
des aliments au même titre que il y a
quelques années les aspects plutôt
nutritionnelle donc on voit une espèce
de glissement de mes préférences des
consommateurs
j'ai maintenant ils vont plus se
concentrer sur le côté naturel qui pour
certains consommateurs en tout cas est
associée à la santé et aux impacts
positifs sur la santé
le fait de raffiner le sucre qui
inquiète peut-être les gens où on
perçoit une grande différence entre le
sucre brut et le sucre blanc alors qu'au
final c'est vraiment juste à la dernière
étape où on va enlever justement que ce
soit une partie des minéraux de la
mélasse pour donner un sucre qui est
blanc mais finalement la différence et
les minimes le
simone lemieux chercheuse en nutrition à
analyser l'ensemble de notre
échantillonnage de produits tous les
produits qu'on m'avait fait parvenir
entre dans la grande catégorie qu'on
appelle les sucres libres et qu'on
devrait s'assurer de limiter leur
consommation
peu importe le produit de kiel sur la
table puis quand je dis ce crédible
c'est vraiment tous les ce qu'on ajoute
nos aliments tout ce qui est ajoutée
dans par l'industrie de la
transformation puis aussi tous ceux qui
sont naturellement présents dans le
mièvre dans les sirops d'un jus de
fruits donc tout ça ce sont les sucres e
div
certains sucres et sirops peuvent
contenir des vitamines des minéraux
on utilise souvent le côté vitamines et
minéraux pour vanter le sucre brut mais
aussi les miels sirops d'érable sirop
d'agavé tout ce quand on compare un
sucre brut un sucre blanc ont pesé
rouart la différence est immense parce
que dans le sucre blanc rien du tout de
toute façon quand on ajoute du sucre
dans une recette à la maison ou quoi que
ce soit on lâche tout pour les vitamines
de l'eau on la joute pour le guppy pour
l'aspect que ça va donner un nouveau
gâteau lalami moller et tout ça donc je
vois pas vraiment l'intérêt de parler
des vitamines et des minéraux dans des
sucres
et si on choisit un sucre plus exotiques
comme par exemple le coco ou le sirop de
yako un tubercule ou encore de fruits
comme les dates des options de
remplacement du sucre présenté comme
plus saine ce qu'on pourrait dire la
même chose le sucre de table ça vient la
voir la betterave sucrière ou de la
canne à sucre donc je pense que rendus
au stade où l' on a extrait le sucre
d'un animant et que le sucre est
concentrée n'ya plus vraiment de
différence d'un produit à l'autre
l'autre sont aiment le goût des dates
super intéressant mais ça s'arrête là le
sucre comme telle la molécule ne va pas
changer sa forme et douceur donc avait
absorbé la même façon dre surtout pas
que le fait qu'il y ait des allégations
santé ou pseudo santé sur les produits
donnent l'impression qu'on peut en
consommer beaucoup plus puisque c'est
santé l'organisation mondiale de la
santé recommande une limite par jour à
ne pas dépasser
on n'aurait pas dépasser 50 g de sucres
libres dans notre bonne alimentation de
2000 calories avec 50 g ca devrait 3
cuillerées à table un petit peu plus la
problématique de la surconsommation
sucre réside beaucoup plus dans la
surconsommation de boissons sucrées que
dans le choix de sucre dans nos biscuits
à la maison ou dans notre café c'est
petit ajout de sucre l'eau dans notre
vie ça fait pas grand chose au final on
peut être tenté aussi par les
édulcorants naturels à base de plantes
ou encore de fruits comme le fruit des
moines au pouvoir sucrant mais sans les
calories
ce qu'on voit c'est oui freud et moi
même si des sucres alcools les rites
stoll xylitol ça qu'on va utiliser parce
que l'aspartame a mauvaise presse
donc c'est comme si le fait de consommer
quelque chose de sucré mais qu' aucune
énergie aucune calorie qui vient avec
ça vient un peu mélangé notre cerveau
c'est sûr que les édulcorants en général
vont entretenir le goût pour le sucre
selon certaines études chez des animaux
ça pourrait finalement faire en sorte
que les gens et ça augmente leur désir
d'aller chercher des vrais aliments
sucrés qui vont leur donner vraiment de
l'énergie
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya un ménage à faire
pour essayer de réduire cette confusion
du consommateur liée s'est ouvert
informations cet hyper personnalisation
des produits qui fait qu' on s'y
retrouve plus lent je pense qu'il faut
rester réaliste d'entropie faire les
choix pour les bonnes raisons d'une
certaine façon il ne pas se tourner vers
la microanalyse des aliments je vais
choisir le sirop d'érable parce que yo
du manga n'importe quand on veut même si
rodez ramenant une recette parce qu'on
veut que ça goûte le sirop d'érable et
on veut peut-être encourager l'économie
locale au passage qui sait très bien